how's it going bros my pimp ah I have
some exciting news for you
we're hosting a game gap what is the
game damn well damn it it's basically
you make a game in a very short period
of time I know for example surgeon
simulator with originally started as a
game jam game the theme of the dam is
Indies vs. PewDiePie you have 72 hours
to make a game and then you bros can
play all of them but I will play for my
channel the top 10 highest voted ones
it's all going to be over at games all
calm the general theme of the whole
thing is fun to play but fun to watch so
it puts the emphasis on that everyone
should enjoy whether you played yourself
or if you watch your legs play ok Nick
I'm very excited to see what's gonna
come out of this Jam
it starts November 21st so mark your
calendar and make sure to be there it's
gonna be 72 hours of pure madness and I
can't wait to see what you pros or naan
breads whatever I don't care I just want
to play your games the next news of the
day is that we have these t-shirts oh I
don't know purpose sorry there look like
this I think they're really awesome I
mean who doesn't want these we have a
ton of cool beautify merch I think you
boys should like it it's cool you can
show late your bro or whatever I don't
know do whatever you want
that's what I always say buy my money
you need to buy all my [ __ ] I mean
just do I have you want that's what I
always say you don't have to do anything
if you want to give me all your money
you could do that another very cool
thing is that thanks to you bros we won
an award
look I it's the golden joystick it was a
voting to win this which made me really
really happy cuz I didn't think I would
win at all so thanks so much to everyone
who voted for me I
like there was a lot of lie like it was
cool
I'm very humbled by this I'm just very
proud of myself but also this community
that we have when I started my gaming
channel four years ago it was literally
to somehow get into video games because
I realized I don't want to study economy
I want a video game is my passion and
that's what I want to do and I feel like
I really
this shows that really that's where we
are and I'm just so happy with that so
thank you that was not inappropriate
sorry that's all I got for you Russ um
I'm gonna start a new series soon I
think a lot of you will enjoy it other
than that I was enjoying the videos that
I'm putting up for you and we're gonna
breakfast you ready for this all right
that's always stay awesome